new in theaters this weekend Annabelle
comes home and yesterday what will you
see this is your weekend ticket
[Music]
everything you see in here is either
haunted cursed or has been used in some
kind of ritualistic practice nothing's a
toy it's safer for these things to be in
here than out there sometimes it's
better to keep the genie in the bottle
Annabelle comes home to theaters this
weekend in this third movie in the
series Annabelle is brought safely to to
demonologists house more specifically
their room of constant artifacts and is
placed safely in a glass case ending
Annabelle's reign of terror forever that
is until the case is open and Annabelle
awakens the many other spirits in the
room leading to a whole new cast of
horrors set upon the family and two
babysitter's oops
[Music]
[Music]
as this is the seventh movie in the
conjuring series filmmaker James Wan is
still attached and not only produces
what has a story credit so it's sure to
bring those familiar scares and more
this movie is for you if you're a fan of
the conjuring movies you're looking for
something scary this summer or if you've
got a taste of Chucky last week and
you've decided to only watch scary doll
movies weird now it looks as though I
didn't why it's a Paul McCartney wrote
they're the Beatles okay and musical
comedy yesterday comes out this weekend
in this what-if story Jack played by
himesh Patel can't seem to make it as a
musician until the global blackout
mysteriously changes of the world by one
little thing do you think you don't know
who the Beatles are erasing the
existence of the band The Beatles
well except from Jack's memory when I
find myself sometimes
sorry I'm just listening to Jack's new
song what's this one called
leave it be don't be confused but armed
with the knowledge of the Beatles music
jack impresses the world with quote his
songs and rises to fame but will being a
fraud eat him up inside will he also
steal Ed Sheeran's music
it's gonna be the greatest album of all
time I've got two men who claim that the
songs are there let's see how this plays
out shall we
[Applause]
please make some noise this movies for
you if a musical comedy sounds good to
you this weekend
you love the Beatles and every movie
celebrating their music or you always
wanted to take credit for someone else's
work
good shirk that is your weekend ticket
what will you see and check back next
week for the final chapter in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is phase 3
[Music]